je voudrais vous dire à quel point nous
avons besoin de vous et pour terminer je
voudrais dire un mot tout particulier à
tous les jeunes qui sont ici et ils sont
nombreux ce soir me viennent me viennent
à l'esprit le viennent à l'esprit ces
mots de bernanos dans le chemin de la
croix des âmes c'était au plus noires de
la seconde guerre mondiale et bernanos
écrivait au jeune français jeunes
français qui métier hier encore que
l'enfance de mon pays une crise sans
précédent vous pousse désormais au
premier rang amis j'ai entrepris de vous
parler comme à des hommes entre le
désastre et nous il n'ya plus que votre
jeune honneur nous sommes les enfants
d'une même des fêtes mais vous seul
pouvez la regarder d'un regard innocent
tenez bon tenez ferme
soyez fidèles tenez bon tenez ferme
si vous êtes fidèles chers amis jeunes
français alors il restera à ses donneurs
au pays à ses donneurs pour vous et à
ses donneurs pour nous chers jeunes qui
est ici ce soir
chers amis nous avons besoin de vous
pour reconstruire une famille politique
qui puisse porter foule tout ce en quoi
nous croyons pour reconstruire cette
famille politique qui a le sens de la
transmission pour reconstruire cette
famille politique qui croit à la force
de la france mais qui droite la force de
la france suppose qu'elle se libère des
fringales s'impose à elle même pour
reconstruire cette famille politique qui
mettra fin à la menace terroriste pour
offrira demain un nouvel espoir à la
france nous avons besoin de vous chers
amis nous sommes les enfants de cette
histoire magnifique
nous sommes les enfants de l'idéalisme
de plateau de la juste mesure d'aristote
nous sommes les enfants de cicéron et de
marc aurèle de cette ampleur vous savez
que chaque matin c'est pour faire
l'oeuvre
on se réveille
nous sommes des enfants des paysans
décrocher l'europe nous sommes des
enfants du chevalier qui ont inventé le
code de l'honneur nous sommes les
enfants de cet héritage des lumières qui
a développé la raison critique
nous sommes les enfants de ce2 14 et des
résistants de 40 qui ont fait notre
liberté d'aujourd'hui au prix de leur
vie
nous devons nous montrer à la hauteur de
cette histoire et nous serons à la
hauteur de cette histoire c'est
exactement ça
je voudrais dans les années qui viennent
avec tous les colistiers au parlement
européen peut paraître votre droit mais
pendant les dix jours qui fuit
il faut que vous soyez notre voie car
vous seul pouvez faire cette victoire
dont nous avons tellement besoin
vous seul vous n'êtes pas venus écouter
vous êtes venus agir
vous n'êtes pas venus écouter vous êtes
venu vous engager et dans dix jours
cette victoire serait la vôtre ont
refondé l'europe et pour rétablir la
france merci de tout coeur merci
infiniment
le